[Music]
good morning John it's January which is
something that I never thought I was
gonna say again and how did I kick off
the new year same way - last year
sledding except this time if possible
the place we were at was actually more
beautiful anyway you know is gonna
happen I know what's gonna happen let's
just have it happen - the video montage
sledding video montage sledding and fun
video montage love sledding winter
sports are the best especially when they
require no skill at all I'm not a skier
not a snowboarder I like to sit down and
go down and this balance only balance I
don't go balance at a sit and I go first
order of business gotta take care of
this the intro not entirely my doing the
music was actually done by a nerdfighter
named Ben who is very obviously made of
Awesome the band called center course
there will be a link to their band over
in the sidebar awesome band thank you
guys so much for doing that it's really
great it works perfectly everybody loves
it pretty much the best part of the
intro so please ooh thank you so my main
order of business today is that I have
been tagged I have been tagged twice
actually possibly more than twice once
by Charlie is so cool like and thoughts
in my head tagged our channel so I'm
just gonna do both of those and John if
you want to do one I think actually you
specifically got attacked by a
nerdfighter Natalie you can say thought
to my head tagged you if you want to but
you got Natalie the tag game basically
means that I have to say five things
about myself that you didn't already
know so number one I am one of the
millions of Americans who despite having
the money to buy health insurance and a
very strong will to have health
insurance does not have health insurance
one more reason why I'm leaning very
strongly toward the left in the upcoming
election um - I hate sesame seeds and I
hate sesame seeds for the same reason
that I don't have health insurance
because I have a disorder in my colon
and sesame seeds irritate my disorder I
don't know what this means
so the doctor says I can't have sesame
seeds and while you like sesame seed
flavored things in early sesame seeds
are just a garnish and now I can't eat
like half of the sandwiches in the world
because they all have sesame seeds on
them it's not
because sesame seeds taste good on buns
it's just like a little sign that says
Hank you can't have this hamburger
because somebody decided to pcs on it
okay
number three for an entire summer during
college I didn't pay for any food now
this has a name they call them freegans
yeah I ate mostly out of the trash
but I also would go to friends houses
and eat their food or go to Katherine
and mom's house and eat her food I
wanted a little zero impact lifestyle
except that I played video games all the
time before I was the mascot at my high
school
I trusted in a wild cat costume when I
danced at all the games that's what I
did
Willy Willy the wild cat that was me and
finally five John Green is not actually
my brother I am a paid actor uh I was
hired by his publishing company to try
and help him sell books and I just I
don't think that it's right to keep
lying to you guys
did you see the YouTube drama report
that said that we weren't brothers and
then I was an environmentalist wacko and
my first name is actually William O
Trevor no no how could you get your news
yep John and I are actually brothers
it's not a metaphor it's not like we're
in the same organized crime thing you uh
ruther kind of brotherhood
we're not half-brothers we're not
adopted we're of the seat of the same
man and we came out of the same woman
that kind of brother maybe that other
one should be my thing my name is
William Henry Greene the second I'm
named after my grandfather and my mom
wanted to call me Hank which I'm glad of
I really like the name Hank and it's
also sometimes a huge pain in the ass
when the bank is like but this check is
made up to hike
Luanne Hank no no no you are William
you're William no I well I'm Hank
I'm I'm William and I'm Hank just give
me my money so now you know those five
things and I get the bag people to
Melissa Jenna Rance Riggs Maureen books
nerdfighter national and Priscilla and
pathos you've all been tagged John we'll
see you tomorrow